We'll illustrate
the distinction between P and
NP by trying to analyze a world
of friends and enemies.
By the way, Lance gets credit for
this example.
His daughters were the right age for
the Twilight movie when it came out.
Everyone in this world is
either a friend or an enemy.
And we'll represent this by drawing
an edge between all the friends like so.
Given all this information,
there are several types of analysis
that you might want to do.
Some easier and some harder.
For instance,
if you wanted to run a dating service,
you'd be in pretty good shape.
Say that you wanted to maximize the
number of matches that you could make
and enhance the number
of happy customers.
Or perhaps you just want to know if
it's possible to get everyone a date.
Well, we have efficient algorithms for
finding matching,
and we'll see some in a future lesson.
Here in this example,
it's possible to match everyone up, and
such a matching is fairly easy to find.
Contrast this with the problem
of identifying cliques.
By clique I mean a set of people who
are all friends with each other.
For instance,
here is a clique of size three.
Every pair of members
has an edge between.
And cliques of that size
aren't too hard to find.
As we look for larger cliques, however,
the problem becomes harder and
harder to solve.